hey Crazy's astronomical distances are
so big they can often be difficult to
imagine things like planets are huge but
then the distances between them are even
bigger so much bigger in fact it's
almost always impossible to show their
sizes and distances to scale at the same
time on top of that the human brain can
sometimes resist the reality of these
numbers the earth is a little under
25,000 miles around but standing on the
ground you can only see a max of about 3
miles which is point zero zero zero zero
one percent of the Earth's surface that
perspective makes the earth was flat
even though it is there's photographic
and video evidence so let's step away
from the earth for a moment to the next
closest thing the moon hmmm I'm going to
need to non-scientists for this
let's ask people on the street as your
attorney I'd recommend against that
really you have to get everyone's
written permission it's messy man hmm I
got it
let's end interview clone to ask my
parents basketball here now what I want
you to imagine is that this is the earth
okay okay so we're scaling the earth
down a little bit and we're measuring
the earth this is basketball okay first
question how big do you think the moon
is if this is the size you're showing
your hands or what I would say this
ain't that big mm-hmm okay what do you
think that baseball baseball okay
Lizabeth Oh
so we would quote close it's a little
smaller than you thought that's okay a
lot of people think that the moon is
bigger than it actually isn't a specific
right all right
just to clarify we're using a basketball
in a tennis ball as scale model the
earth has a diameter of about seven
thousand nine hundred and eighteen miles
and a basketball has a diameter of about
nine and a half inches that's a scale of
fifty 2.8 million to one the moon has a
diameter of 2159 mile making it three
point six times smaller than the earth a
tennis ball has the diameter of a
two and a half inches a near-perfect
match to our scale okay
back to my parents if this is the earth
and this is the moon
mm-hmm how far away is the moon here I
want to say over here over there okay
what do you think that scale yeah yeah
this go right about there these are very
typical answers from people who have
never seen the numbers before I just
can't wait to see the reaction to the
truth wah-wah you wanted a half hour
wait actually you have 24 feet are you
okay so where is that Wow right about
there hello a lot further away that a
book it is 24 feet because I know that
that's the closest thing to the virtual
everything it almost rather the
International Space Station is mazing
loading up the sky rice per se right
there seriously yes Wow this is why it
took you know four days to get to the
moon they would be most amazing way over
there that's right people think the
earth and the moon look like this when
in reality they look like this I always
make a point in my videos to draw the
Earth Moon system to scale because it's
one of the few astronomical distances I
can actually do that with to put this in
perspective though the distance from the
center of the earth to the center of the
moon is 30 Earth surface to surface you
can fit 29 and a half Earth's in between
the Earth and the moon hey as long as
you line them up on their side you can
fit all of the other seven planets in
there together it's crazy we can
actually measure how far away the moon
is using the delay for reflected lasers
there are mirrors that NASA astronauts
put on the moon to reflect a laser back
to earth and the round trip takes about
two and a half seconds okay
so the moon is a lot farther away than
it looks but just for fun let's say the
earth of the moon were this close
what would that look like in the sky for
this we need something called angular
size which is measured in degrees or
radians rather than
something like miles or meter it's the
angle the object takes up in your field
of view for the real moon that's a
little over half a degree the real moon
doesn't take up that one to the sky but
if it were closer say this close instead
of looking normal like this it would
look like this spanning almost 14
degrees in your field of view
absolutely terrifying thankfully it's
much farther away than that but let's
take one more step away from there the
Sun is over eight hundred and sixty four
thousand miles across and about 93
million miles away in our scale bottle
that makes the Sun eighty six and a half
feet across which looks like this
sitting on an American football field
I'd like to remind you the earth is
still a basketball on this scale
thankfully it's not this close to the
Sun to scale the distance between them
is about one point eight mile the Sun is
barely visible and the basketball earth
is far too small to see other stars are
too far away to even place on this scale
the universe is vast cold and empty and
we are so small and insignificant the
only hope humans have of being important
is to each other so did this video leave
you in a pit of despair or does it
motivate you to be less of a jerk I'd
like to know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we took a small look
at light inside materials from our
response time a Thrasher and others
pointed out that my answer lacked the
detail you usually expect from a science
of silent video it honestly I don't
disagree with you but there are a few
things going on here I should clarify
one the video was originally longer but
I cut some sections out of the last
minute I did this mainly because I suck
at animating wave interference and I
just couldn't animate those sections
there are more details about that in my
most recent vlog - I purposefully left
out a discussion of group vs. phase
velocity Lucas fires brought it up in a
comment thread if you're interested I
just felt like it was going to
overcomplicate the conversation light
waves inside materials are unimaginably
complicated I tried to simplify things a
little by having only two atoms in the
picture you get light wherever the wave
fronts overlap in hindsight I might have
oversimplified a bit and 3 the video
wasn't about why light flows out in
glass the title was does light flow down
in glass it was never meant to go into
any real depth as Krishna COC pointed
out I was trying to connect it to my
previous video on math and language that
being said you clearly prefer more
detailed videos since that's what
separates this channel from other
science channel I will keep that in mind
moving forward never Tower apps how the
refractive index fits visuals wave
interference is really complicated so
we'd like to avoid it if at all possible
the refractive index is our way to do
that theoretically it contains a bunch
of information mainly how far apart the
atoms are how their electron clouds
respond to the incoming light and what
the wavelength is delighted yes the
refractive index does slightly depend on
the wavelength that's why we can get
things like rainbow anyway the delay
between when the original light passes
through an atom and when that atom sends
out its own light can affect how those
waves combine inside the glass it rahem
shallower went to the dark place and
brought a quantum mechanics
theoretically speaking the photon takes
all possible paths simultaneously
allowing it to have wave interference
with
why I also purposefully avoided this
because if you intend on using quantum
mechanics to explain something you
better be prepared to interpret quantum
mechanics I was not and I'm not sure any
of you would have been either all right
crazy you're all amazing and thanks
again to all my patrons on patreon
you're making this mad scientist crazy
life a little more manageable see you
all next time and thanks for watching
[Music]